is there a device you can give yeah to
people that to uh young girls and boys
dreaming somewhere in Africa of how to
change the world that's right and by the
way I want to say there are bigger
beacons there are better beacons than me
I just happen to be someone who
has the chance of talking to you right
now
uh and one of my goals is to open the
same doors that were open for me because
together our voice
there's such Amazing Stories out there
and um so bigger beacons better beacons
out there
one thing here for me the reason why
I do what I'm doing right now and it's
almost to the point of self-destructing
my own health
I feel invested with such the mission of
I have been afforded the truth
so it is my moral duty to try to take it
around I know I sound people sometimes
say when I listen to I feel like I'm I'm
talking to a to a priest and I'm like
because the gospel I received the gospel
so anyway but the thing is Lex who tells
you these things
to this day when they talk about the
poverty of Africa what do they talk
about this didn't even telling you oh
yes because of criminalism it's because
of racism it's because of imperialism
it's because they're stealing you know
raw material blah blah blah is is any of
those
called you know like guilty to some
level of where we are today uh one of
maybe part of a reason where we are
today maybe maybe is that the only
reason or the overwhelming reasons no is
that unsurmountable absolutely not so
for me don't stay in that place of um
that steals and robs you of your agency
so so I think it's important for people
to a get the right diagnosis as to why
we are where we are because what you and
I just talked about
the mainstream does not talk about this
when they even talk about Africa in
terms that you know are not the usual
suspect of oh famine is building over
there war is building over here oh we're
having Ebola is coming all of that stuff
even when they were talking about the
monkey pox which at first you know
um in this wave it started with white
people in Europe well even in the many
newspapers you pull out it's black
people which make monkey pucks on their
on their skin I'm like wait a second
this time around we it did not start
with us so why are you always showing us
when it's right now happening to white
people you know
um so so all of that is happening so for
me the thing is
we the world simply right now
does not have the right diagnosis as to
why this continent right now despite all
of its riches because Lord knows it's
got riches starting with its young
population 75 of a population in my
country is below the age of 25 years old
so when we're talking I know we're
talking about you know repopulation you
know it's important we're gonna have to
go for that
maybe you'll get me going about climate
change I don't know but anyway
um so here my point is a we need the
right diagnosis as to why this continent
is the poorest continent in the world
despite its riches starting with its
young people
all the natural resources diversity in
land people cultures languages
everything that make that make for a
great ingredients for for awesomeness
despite all of that we are the poorest
region in the world people need to know
that the reason why that is
it's because we also happen to be the
most overrated over regulated region in
the world at the end of the day what
Africa as and I dare to say Africa here
and treat it as one we are 54 countries
55 depending on how you count yet we
almost for a tiny minority of these
countries we almost all lack one of the
most crucial freedoms that there are if
you're serious about Prosperity building
we lack economic freedom and economic
freedom is the thing that unlocks that
human potential of the young people just
yes for them to run to run with your
ideas to start businesses or to start
initiative it doesn't have to be
for-profit all the time right but it is
it is it is this is this thing that gets
you to get up and go and do something
criticized by creating young people are
naturally wired to want to criticize by
creating they're not sitting around
waiting or complaining usually unless
you put them in a tiny box and they have
no other way to go and in this situation
what they do you know let's talk about
pre-colonial Africa of four favors
before slavery ever happened there were
black people in the con on the continent
you see when we talk about the story of
black people and Africans Africans you
know black people in Africa for most of
us even me
I noticed that unconsciously it starts
with slavery but you're like no we
weren't there before before white man
ever set foot who were we what were we
doing in our diversity
um what um economic systems where are we
running on
um and then you realize that for most of
them they were free marketeers and they
were very much on the free trade on the
Freya Enterprise side so even that is a
reinforcement this is the place where we
do not understand our history so proper
diagnosis Africa is the poorest region
in the world because it happens to be
the most of a regulated region in the
world lacks economic freedom number two
what do we do about that we gotta become
serious about reforms economic reforms
so that um we can become beacons of uh
free markets
just like the Asian tigers that's what
the Asian tigers did they had to become
serious Singapore Taiwan you know uh
South Korea those guys had to become
serious about the free markets
you know when uh you know he's just like
we got to do something and he looked
around and he realized at some point we
got to make these reforms and he went on
to that journey of reforms making his
country one of the most free market you
know countries in the world and voila
the magic happened back in the you know
in the 30s of the stock market crash and
the Great Depression and everything the
world and with all the lies but we're
told uh to to the world coming from the
Soviet Union Stalin while they were
starving and dying of the verbs but oh
no you know I mean Durante was telling
the world that uh oh no no everything is
going well nobody's dying when we know
now and getting surprises based on this
stuff but then the world went on
believing that oh no
um capitalism failed this is this this
um you know
um crash that you had in the in the in
the stock market is proof this is what
list stage capitalism produces you guys
always have your big ups and downs and
by that time it was so hard on people
that they're like we're done with this
and at the same time we're told the lies
coming out of the Soviet Union but
supposedly the communism was doing just
fine and you're at the point where the
free market concept almost died and it's
um you know the the Asian tigers who
kind of helped you know bring that idea
back to life right uh their success
having used free markets and so for me
we gotta have we gotta make a new
commitment to a free markets on this
continent if we want to go anywhere if
we want to go anywhere and the timing is
perfect because the young people there's
a
there is a kind of freedom for that
revolutionary free markets in this whole
Space exactly and
and I'm hearing in that because
something's really cool say it again
come on Lex I don't know which part you
said English is my second language too
no you said you said there's something
revolutionary yeah in in that because
you know how young people are attached
with a revolution and how you know I
understand look look Lex I understand
and I am willing to give the benefits of
a doubt
to some of these socialists who cut who
came to it because they had to witness
some of a horrors of you know of their
times you know
there's a revolution right behind that
it's ultimately yeah uh uh criticized by
creation exactly exactly but violent
revolution is never the answer but
that's what they went for in 1789 in
France in over French Revolution
um and then and you know marks and
Engels you know they're promoting these
ideas that usually for them justifies
violent revolution learning all of these
people the
I am with them when they say that they
want
um to see equal rights for people of
course I don't agree with their
therefore we need to push for equal
outcomes yeah equal rights is right but
equal outcomes is not right so but I am
with them for all the way to equal
rights but this is where the two paths
go this way and also they're they're
none the fact that they have no issue
with violent revolution and people get
killed uh you know people get put in
gulags and people get that's not right
so what you just said here just give me
goosebumps because
there is revolution in the free markets
but that's the type of Revolution we
want the revolution that comes from
people creating criticizing by creating
is one of the best forms of Revolution
if you ask me that's the most sexy way
of Revolution criticized by creating by
what you're gonna go shoot people or be
like uh what's his name
um Che Guevara who tells you I love it's
in writing I love nothing more than to
fry this the the brain of a man with his
gun really well in terms of sexy uh
there is power in that message of the
oppressor the abuser the enemy that has
abused their power they need to be
destroyed and there's power in that in
the message of that violence
unfortunately the lessons of History
show that the violence
um one doesn't work but it does it does
the following there's something about
human nature as the old cliche goes that
power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely is the people who
are in charge of committing that
violence it does something to their head
the first person you kill the second
person you kill for some reason you lose
your ability the compassion for other
humans even if you began as a
revolutionary as the Soviets did
fighting for the worker for the for the
rights and the the basic Humanity of the
people that really do the work
us you lose you lose the plot somehow
because of the violence so in that way
it seems like the lesson at least of
this part of the human history until the
robots take over is that the economic
um Freedom free markets and protecting
those and allowing the anyone from your
country
to dream and to make that dream a
reality by creating it with as few uh
sort of uh roadblocks as possible
exactly so so that's why for me the
message is very clear is what we talked
about today the reason why Africa is the
first region in the world is because it
happens to be the most over-regulated
um region in the world and for some
people who might be you know put off by
it because they're like oh just talking
about let's it fair no
let me put it maybe in a way that you
can understand do you think that it
should be as easy for any person in
Africa for any entrepreneur in Africa to
Enterprise than it is for any person in
Scandinavia to Enterprise if your answer
is yes which I would hope it is then you
have a moral obligation to work with me
to make my country and as a whole my
continent more free markets it's that
simple at that point there's no like yes
but on the other hand no
and for me on that question and I yet
have to find somebody who claims to say
no if you say no then we have a whole
other problem I'm not even talking to
you at that point anymore so yeah so
it's just to clarify uh you know there's
a perception in some reality that's
Scandinavian countries have elements of
socialism in their politics and their
society in their even in their economics
so at the very least
uh Africa should have in terms of
economic indices should be as free as a
scandian naming countries you're just
giving that example yes because
Scandinavian they do have a
subsidized you know like welfare system
that's what a small socialized welfare
system but the way they make their money
is very very much the way over free
markets so there is how you make your
money and then there's how you maybe
decide as as a as a country to
redistribute it right and so even there
even in the in the in the in Scandinavia
um again yes they have more economic
freedom so when from their legs where we
go is
my job and my goal is for every single
African young and old
to know
what I have come to learn
we are not doomed
um it's not over for us
we will never catch up the time for
catch-up is is gone but guess what we've
got a strong strong possibility and
chance to LeapFrog
and LeapFrog we will
it is still time but for that to happen
like I said we need to know what we just
talked about today because that is not
what the mainstream keeps us at rest
with when you go to the World Bank they
don't necessarily work along these lines
they're still it's it's not when you go
to universities
um I will ask you MIT the MIT econ
department or even some of most of the
professors are they free market oriented
we find that oftentimes in Academia
there there is a strong anti-captus bias
there's a strong anti-free Market bias
so this is a problem this is a problem
nobody cares about the economist anyway
uh in MIT the spirit of the entrepreneur
Burns bright not in the economics
Department because they just write op-ed
articles but in the dreamers the young
undergrads that actually build something
no I get that but then we cannot be
stifling their efforts yes by putting
these artificially made regulations and
laws that standing there and clipped
their wings so so that's why when you
were saying what advice do you give to
them the advice I give to them is
each one of them they have to pay
attention to this to this discourse we
just had I don't ask anybody to agree
with me on face value go back do like I
had to do I come very much from the left
to the left if you can believe that but
I had to have my own intellectual
journey and in this case my intellectual
Journey was very much complimented by my
own life having to build these companies
on two separate continents and having to
I was I had front row seat of the
differences at first I thought it was
this way just because we're poor then
therefore we're messed up and therefore
it's like this but eventually I learned
that no we're poor because we lack
economic freedom and if the country
allows its citizens the economic freedom
to Enterprise then they become rich so
yeah I had it upside down you see and so
it's important for people to know that
so number one know your facts because
your facts will Empower you
in this case I like to use that word
facts will Empire and they will even
furthermore they will power you Empower
Empower you because Empower is like
inside and powers that can push you
forward and up so that's what it does to
know the facts
and then go on and look around you where
are the best practices of this who is at
The Cutting Edge of a free market we're
starting away there
people don't necessarily be left behind
or anything like that we we're in 2022
for quite a sake we don't have to do
entrepreneurship the same way maybe it
was done 50 years ago 100 years ago when
as a community as a people we were maybe
less enlightened because of our times
right we can we can update this thing
and move forward but update is
definitely not uh build back uh build
back uh what do they call it build back
new or whatever we're calling it The WF
you know like whatever whatever nonsense
and you know stuff they're smoking over
there it's not that where there are some
principles that are Universal and that
stand the test of time
those we have to keep and on top add the
new new things we learned from from our
times and from life so that's what I
want them to know learn new facts be
empowered empowered
and then look around think about the and
look to see where the best practices are
around the world because the world is
yours you might be African but the world
is yours so stop this nonsense of oh
well it's done by white people so we're
not going to do it get the best that
exists in humanity for what you're
trying to solve
and on top of that put your own twist
right Bitcoin is all of hours to take
Bitcoin is not the white man's thing so
therefore oh come on you know because
you know we have a misguided Pride we're
not going to use Bitcoin because this
white man stuff Bitcoin is Matthew idiot
math is universal so it belongs to all
of us there's no color exactly in uh in
the space of Economics ideas
and there's a chance to LeapFrog too
exactly which is really really powerful
exactly because here we will LeapFrog
and Lex I'm not crazy this is this is
gonna happen you mark my words
but it's gonna happen if as many people
hear what we're talking about today
because at some point
the solution is not going to come it's
not me it's not it's going to come from
the wisdom of a crowd this is why I love
the crowd there's no better wisdom than
the crowd and that's also why I Believe
In The Free markets this concept of
emergent order there's no way there's no
Central planning that is smart enough
that has a level of Intel that street
level people have
trying to create something it's just we
just have to be humble there's just
something at the bottom of a pyramid
that just bubbles up and happens they're
the best I think the cynicism the idea
that people are dumb is at the core of a
lot of things that
prevent the flourishing of societies you
know this kind of anecdotally people are
like ah everyone's stupid and people say
that jokingly but the reality is
people are incredible they have the
capacity for kindness for love for
Innovation for Brilliance in all kinds
of Dimensions you might be you might
suck at math but you might be amazing at
carpentry you have to find that thing
and there's something about when there's
a freedom to find that thing and people
interact and get excited about [ __ ]
together and then they they build it's
if you look at authoritarian at places
that limit that freedom
at the core I think is the idea that
people are dumb let us take care of
everything we'll come up with the rules
and the regulations because people are
too dumb to manage things themselves and
that and then that idea builds builds on
top of itself where you think that there
the entire populace is much lesser than
the the wise Sage is sitting at the top
then you add violence on top of that in
at least the corruption and uh to
corrupting of just the human mind of the
leaders and the whole thing is uh
becomes a giant mess the antidote to
that is
economic freedom for people to have a
freedom to Enterprise and um look
um Lex when we allow for that to happen
have you looked around lately and look
at the level of um Niche that has
happened in this country I mean you have
clubs where you you have places where
people are into guitar strings you know
like some of them like it's it's all
about guitar strings and offers it's all
about the best cupcakes and others it's
all about this this new crypto thing
over here and however it's like hair
best you know wait it's when you allow
us because
seven billion Geniuses each one of us I
believe came to this world with
something something that only he or her
possesses and that is the genius and it
is their contribution to the human
problem